anyone else ever have a parent or mother
tell them that they cannot leave the house
unless they look presentable
my mom would literally stop me in my tracks and tell me
what are you doing change out of those sweats
brush your hair
so I grew up with the idea that you always had to look presentable
you don't have to you know
put on a ball gown but look presentable
and that is one of the greatest gifts my mom passed down to me
if you look presentable this will open so many doors for you
people be kinder to you more generous
I'm not saying that's all you should have going for you
but if you look presentable
Most people will wanna be your friend you’ll probably get a promotion at work
your life will genuinely be way easier
so if your mom never taught you this
Before you leave the house make sure you look a little presentable